hi Charles how are you this morning I'm
great my brother how you doing I'm doing
okay are you going to buy the Floyd
Mayweather Conor McGregor fight probably
not I don't think it's going to be a
good fight so I'm probably not going to
buy it you know normal if I thought was
going to be a good fight I would go but
I don't think another guy can just pick
up another pro sport and beat one of the
greatest boxers ever so I'm probably not
going to buy it best fight you attended
was wet Hagler turns in Las Vegas back
in the day that's probably the best one
probably the best short fight in the
history of boxing so that's probably my
favorite one I've been to I've been to
probably 100 um I love I'm going to the
triple G Canelo fight I wouldn't miss
that when I think that's got a chance of
being spectacular but listen you can't
pick up another guy's sport and think
you're gonna beat the best it just as
just impossible we talked we talked
about a variety of things this morning
we did want to look back on the dream
team as 25 years ago yesterday you guys
won the gold medal does it feel like he
was 25 years ago it doesn't but uh you
know but then it brings back so many
great memories just being around those
guys for a month or so and how I'm
selfish everybody was and how well we
got along I think that was probably I
tell people we never had an issue you
know Chuck Dale had two starting lineups
nobody ever complained and just
unselfishness of those guys you know
especially a lot of what we have going
on in the NBA today well guys don't want
to play with other great players but you
got to be like you're kidding me right
you want to play with other great
players you the notion that you want
your own team it's so silly and stupid
like I just don't understand this
generation like you want to play with
other great players it just makes the
game easier I mean why would you not
want to play with LeBrons
who cares who gets all the credit I mean
you get credit by winning you make a lot
of money it's just interesting how the
dynamics of this game has changed well
guys more worried about their brand then
they are it's like you know the
objective of this thing is to win but do
you have more respect than for Durant
who's who's willing to admit hey I want
to win a championship I'm going to
Golden State and I don't have a problem
being the second or third guy or second
or third option whereas Kyrie saying hey
I'm done with having I'm playing the
little brother to the big brother here I
want to be out on my own well I wasn't
down with Kevin Durant cuz I first of
all they had a better team Oklahoma City
had a better team than the Warriors T
and I think you've heard Iguodala Liam
said the good the last couple years
Oklahoma City Thunder they were the best
team in the NBA so I didn't agree with
Kevin going to Golden State but I don't
understand how you know I don't
understand this Kyrie situation at all I
mean you know he's a terrific player
he's playing with LeBron I mean what do
you mean you want to be the big brother
first of all you would a big brother
y'all won 20 games you would a big
brother y'all won 20 games it's hard to
do this thing by yourself you know I've
been a one-man band you know I look at
guys like Allen Iverson's been a one-man
band you want as much help as possible
because the objective you could to get
through the gauntlet of the NBA playoffs
you have to have some firepower a couple
of things when I go back to the 25th
anniversary of the dream team and I
don't know if it was more fun on the
floor off the floor it felt like it was
it might have been equal maybe had more
fun off the court than you did on the
court during that that run oh you know
it's a great question you know I tell
you that no it was so easy playing with
those guys you know you know it's kind
of interesting I'm not comparing myself
to any of these guys but I want to make
the point like when I got to Phoenix
the game I want MVP and I was a much
better player and Phil
Bethea I just didn't have enough help
and when I got the Phoenix I got Dan
Majerle Kevin Johnson and Mark West and
Halle vanillin says about those guys
knit was just easy for me so anything
you saw that this year with Kevin Durant
Kevin Durant's not a better player
he just got those other guys that makes
it look easy so the point I'm trying to
make is when I when you plan with when
you you lob the ball to Scottie Pippen
instead of Shelton Jones you a lot
better player you know and that's not a
knock on Shelton John right yeah yeah no
no it trust me when you think oh I do
lie we ran a fast-break and I just threw
it up in the air and Scottie Pippen
dumped it
I will never thought about doing that
pass the ball to David Robinson Patrick
Ewing on a pick-and-roll is a little bit
different than pastors of a new hole if
you had Scotty and Michael didn't what
would happen if I ever had Scotty yeah
Scotty was a terrific all-around
basketball player I said I tell people
him and Horace Grant what the best two
defenders I hate it playing against
those guys because if you want a double
team you you had no room for error but
if ice wave that Phoenix if I switch you
in Jordan and you run the Bulls and he
was on Phoenix who wins the championship
well I think we win a championship I
mean you remember you got I mean I don't
you know dad John Paxson who obviously
put the DECA in our heart but I thought
Horace Grant to me is one of the most
underrated players you know people take
him for granted because you if you
remember when he went to Atlanta they
beat the Bulls so I always thought
Horace Grant was on to read it really
good players and archives of the NBA
Charles Barkley Hall of Famer joining us
Dan Patrick show Mark Cuban said Colin
Kaepernick would have been on a team by
now if he was an NBA player well you
know I was all hypothetical I think what
Colin is doing has done is has been
awesome
I think his causes is terrific but there
are ramifications and he's paying for
those you know you know for every action
there's a reaction I mean you look at
the greatest athlete of all time a hamid
Ali when he didn't go in the draft there
were ramifications he didn't get to
fight he didn't get to fight for three
years so as noble as what Colin is doing
and it's very noble but there are
consequences like I say you think about
the greatest ever Ali you know he took
his stance but he didn't get to fight
for three years so for every action
there is a reaction and it's unfortunate
it's very unfortunate but when you take
a stance on certain things there is a
price to pay is that simple yeah and you
know there's nothing wrong with
disagreeing what Colin Kaepernick did if
you're an owner of an NFL team I I think
that we you know we look at Kaepernick
what he did he understood that there was
a risk that he was taking I don't know
if he wants to play anymore and almost
feels like he he likes being that martyr
that he can't get on a roster I haven't
heard anything from him that says I
can't wait to play this is what I want
to do this is you know I don't even know
what what the bigger picture is and
maybe it is this cause then you know Dan
first of all you have a great point if
so it's Colin called me and he's not
number one I was what I would do if I
was him I would sit there I would do one
interview or sit-down interview because
I don't think I've heard was the last
time you heard something from him
like I can't remember the last time I've
heard words come out of his mouth you
know you got people you know so we could
witness you know this is might be the
stupidest generation of journalism in
the history of civilization Dan we got
guys are going on like I'm watching
certain networks and you got these
idiots all the time about what does
LeBron mean when he tweeted this and I'm
like you guys need to really get a life
I told you to stop watching those shows
you know what I'm trying to catch up on
how
I got the white man uh-huh you know this
getting ready close to football start
just starting I got to know what's going
on with the training camps and
everything it didn't the baseball
playoffs are heating up so that's all
the reason I'm watching I don't want to
sit around the guy says well this guy
tweeted this he said this but this is
what he really meant I'm like come on
man you guys are a bunch of damn idiots
I mean we this generation of news
journalism it's just crazy
but the point I was trying to make is
Colin Kaepernick I have not heard a word
from him in probably over a year so I
don't know if he wants to play you know
everybody saying where he's we and I do
think there is some blackballing going
on but I wish he would do one sit-down
interview don't be tweeting because you
know cuz everybody kid I can't be one
reason I don't do social media is number
one I want to talk to all these damn
idiots out there but also I love when
people tell me what I meant to say no
you asked me what I said I'll tell you
what the hell I want to say don't try to
parse my words but I wish he would do a
sit-down then you would be a great
person to have him in studio one day and
just talk to him for an hour and let him
see what he wants to say but he needs to
say something because I'm tired of
people trying to speak for this kid one
other thing here is and we're talking
about Josh Rosen the UCLA quarterback
and wide-ranging interview with bleacher
report but if I said to you when you
were in college at Auburn that you could
major in being an athlete and with that
came understanding you take a business
class picking an agent finances
balancing a checkbook public speaking
would you have majored in been being an
athlete or majored in basketball if they
allowed you to do that well the problem
I had with the whole Josh Rosen thing is
number one he's on top of the food chain
Dan so he he don't have to worry about
getting an education and things like
that see this is my biggest problem
these people get on TV talking about
amateurism and they're using these kids
you know the whole system is kind of out
of way
but most of these kids don't have to get
real jobs they need an education just
rosin going to be a number one pick he
can just go to class he can just go
there and play football but what about
see I always worry about the other 99%
especially the black players one of
these other black players who ain't
going to be a number one draft pick who
ain't never gonna play a pro sport you
know one thing I do get offended about
the black community is we don't value
education like I say it's a system flaw
of course the system is flawed but I
don't want some rich white kid who's
going to be a number one draft pick
talking about just we wasting our time
well most of those kids not wasting
those times most of those kids need that
free education to be successful in life
and he might be a nice kid but let me
tell you something I don't want any rich
white kid telling black kids no don't
worry about this stuff just come here
and play football those kids ain't got
no chance of going to the NFL those kids
need that education so even though his
point he got some point man I don't want
any rich white kid who's gonna be one
two or three in the draft I saw that
list last week telling these young black
kids no just come here and play football
and then after four years then got no
education and they never gonna step foot
in the NFL I hate that message calm down
can you talk to you get ready please my
brother you take care of yourself man
keep up the great work thank you when
you got the courage to come back out to
Tahoe and playing a tournament come on
I'll get you in dude I just got my knee
replaced that's why I didn't come out
there this year well about this how
about next summer I got I mean I might
not do it the Hall of Fame asked for my
me
Springfield asked for my knee I had my
knee replaced just probably watch your
knee just sitting on you ass every day
talking on a microphone you didn't see
the aerial display I put on when I was
younger that's why I'm paying the price
now Charles did you go to Dayton yet
like there was air Dan before air jor
dan just to let you I don't remember
days making those deep runs in March
Madness I may not miss that the Patrick
era we we focused on the NIT back then
well see you see think about it though
then if you thank God you got your
education if you want to just play
basketball you know what you wouldn't be
dead Patrick Ivy legend I would have
majored in being an athlete if I could
have and you want to be important all
this but now yes I would yes I would
thank you John alright man thanks for
having they have a great week alright
that's Charles Barkley the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience